for the first time we're hearing from a
member of the team who rescued a young
woman after her car plunged off a
California cliff 23 year old Angela
Hernandez survived for seven days she
was pulled up 250 feet from the foot of
the cliff after hikers found her Friday
media VOD al has new details of the
rescue that she was still alive as
incredible Sergeant Dustin Hedberg was
one of the first on scene after getting
an emergency call that Angela Hernandez
had been found when they told me over
the radio that she was alive I actually
had to ask again a few minutes later to
make sure that I had heard that right
hiker Chelsea Moore called 911 and her
husband discovered Angela's Jeep Friday
we asked her like were you in the Jeep
and she said that was my Jeep
authorities had been looking for
Hernandez for a week not knowing she had
plummeted down a steep cliff on a long
stretch of coastal highway Monterey
County Sheriff Steve Bernal there was no
obvious signs at that location that a
car gone over a lot of people don't
realize just how rugged the Big Sur
coast is Hedberg and his team hoisted
Hernandez to the top of a cliff where
she was airlifted to a hospital we had
to build a rope system using the trees
at the edge of the cliff side for
anchors and a pulley system to pull her
and the rescuer up in a Facebook post
Hernandez says she had swerved off the
road to avoid hitting an animal she says
she suffered a brain hemorrhage
fractured ribs broken collarbones and a
collapsed lung for her to survive for
seven days on the coast with waves
crashing over you at times with injuries
that she had is amazing for CBS this
morning
Miguel Los Angeles we said it yesterday
it's a strong will to survive yeah big
plans for Angela how that